for a guy with as many fears as i have
yeah it's kind of astounding but you're
eating you go to uh soul food
restaurants drink your kool-aid call
dead people every week i mean what you
do in the course of outside of your
illustrious career period parties
do you know who you want speaking at
your funeral no
you don't you haven't thought this
through you've thought it through oh
come on of course no he's looking at his
wife how are you
49. and
do you uh it is your family
is it family history are your parents
alive yeah i have a cardiologist go to
cardiologists every nine months why
because i my history of strokes and
blood
heart attacks so that's the thing that's
going to get me so i'm on blood pressure
medicine i do the stress test the ct i
do all of it to make sure that i'm
healthy and you've already hired a
speaker for the eulogy no but you
haven't thought out your funeral do you
want a funeral
um wait hold on i don't want to die okay
but but you like i've thought it out i
was thinking for my 50th yeah i might do
a mock funeral did you see that on curb
your enthusiasm no yeah for really did
that albert brooks had uh albert brooks
and i think was the first episode this
season albert brooks decided to have a
funeral before because you want to hear
people say nice things about you why are
they saying all these nice things when
you're gone and you can't hear it so he
was upstairs in his bedroom and they
invited everybody and they had speakers
it was on there but you should who do
you want to speak at your funeral well
you want me to
i would love for you to would you i mean
you'd be a nice guest
i would i don't want to and i'll tell
you right to your face i'm turning it
down i don't want to speak of you here
patrice's funeral was apparently
amazing like yeah yeah yeah everyone
like they said that that the people that
went up and spoke it was one of the most
amazing experiences anyone was at and
you go well i want i want my kids
i guess my kids don't really give a [ __ ]
their dad's dead but like i want
i i want my life to be celebrated i like
because a lot of people i went to bob
sagets that was pretty amazing and sad
and the people that spoke at it were
amazing and funny and touching and
i don't know but who's that for i mean
once we're dead who's it for it's for
the i think it's for your kids
right like do you care like it do would
you want your dad to have a funeral
do you want who do you want to speak at
my dad i don't know i hate even talking
about it no but honestly jackie when i
die who do you want to speak i don't
want to think about it hold on no hang
on you got to think about it because
think about this right hypothetically
you know who your dad's been close with
in comics what like like if i got up on
stage to talk to your daughter but you'd
be like hold on he don't even [ __ ]
know my dad no yeah right i wouldn't no
no i wouldn't say that i think i would
appreciate no i would appreciate anyone
who had
kind words or that he's touched but even
or even beyond that if i was dead if i
was dead even though you were sad and
bert came up i know what you would do
you would go tell the period party story
i want to get my mind off the fact that
my father just died yeah yeah like you'd
want you'd want you'd want like uh
i don't know i thought about that might
definitely know that my funeral is going
to be on a tuesday okay because all the
comics are in town okay good i'm not
gonna have a [ __ ] sunday funeral no
one's gonna show up no you're right it's
a good that's a tough day tuesday good
idea through we got this plan yeah i
want to do it uh i would like to do it
at like the greek
wow nice venue yeah
hollywood bowl to make sure they're full
there you want to make a video now like
just you don't have to release it until
then i got a great idea i know a guy
who's got a hologram machine it wouldn't
be shocked to see me
pop up out of the casket when i was 22
years old i got involved with the
russian mafia here's how it happened
that's how my that's how my funeral ends
that's how my funeral ends that's how my
funeral ends i do have a hologram
machine here in the studio where after
we do this podcast we'll make a hologram
of you for the funeral for the funeral
and i just pop up i rip off my shirt and
i go
guys it's not over when i was 22 years
old i got involved with the russian
mafia here's how it happened the crowd
goes nuts right and i tell the whole
machine story i love it oh
my god what if i what if i what if i
what if i what if i what if i
what
what if i recorded a message to be
played at my funeral for my family
that's never happened
as a hologram i love it it's a hologram
oh my god that's so touching you're
seeing this i'm dead okay you don't
start that's that's a little morbid but
you're like but they know it it's the
audience that's a little morbid we're
talking about your funeral no go ahead
what do you say
about that i love it
if nothing else this might be a business
model you should yeah no
i would love
if nothing else we could play this
episode of mike podcast at your funeral
i would love to i would love to speak at
my funeral i would love to speak at my
funeral uh we all miss bert here's howie
mandel does stuff this is from
no he wants episode 51. speaking
don't you wouldn't it would like
wouldn't what if you just said passing
words to the people you loved at your
funeral they didn't know about it right
all of a sudden the holocaust comes up
and you're like
i'm gonna cry this is a great idea
you're like what's up every i want to
thank everyone for showing up
uh
i just want to say things to the people
that affected me in life and you go
through and you're like tommy um i my my
life was enriched and blossomed my
security my financial security because
of you you were a great friend i will
always love you i and just go to it
yeah oh yeah i talked to my dad last
night about tom for an hour and i got
really emotional i talked about when my
dad is getting older and we were talking
about friends and how they affect you
and how you know you know
i was talking about joe and tom and how
they've really affected my life in so
many amazing amazing ways and so um
it would be great to do at your funeral
is to let everyone know how you felt
about them
and and because then can you do that
ahead of time
no but you may
you may get caught off guard
you this is just a safety catch this is
just a thing have you told joe and tom
how are you told me i've actually told
both joe and tom recently recently uh i
haven't actually i haven't told tom
i kind of have maybe a little bit you
want to call him and want to call him
and tell him what you think of him no
because you might die on tuesday
yeah but i just record a hologram and
send it to him
you don't want to phone them hey can we
do surprise holograms when you're dead
and they go to your front door and you
hear knock on the door and then the
whole machine's set up right and then
they're like who the [ __ ] is it it opens
but i'm already dead i've been dead a
week and i'm like hey buddy i want to
talk to you
it's like to catch a predator with dead
people
[Music]
you